what would my next three to five moves be
combined with learning how to swim with the river
i'm gonna leave and get some water because
i've been talking way too much i'll be right
back and i want to see what kind of plan
you might come up with with that okay
okay all right got it got it
oh my god this is this is a lot
got a minute come on veggie oh and he's not
streaming so we can't see oh oh no it's gonna be
this exact checkmate it's gonna be the checkmate
here it comes starter sees it no question he's
good to do this mate oh boy oh boy oh oh queen
oh my gosh oh my gosh you blunted the queen does
benji see it does benji see it benji do you see
this oh he has to see it look at benji's face
he's in shock oh he took the queen and sardosh
loses the queen benji is so confused he's smiling
no the tragedy not the queen oh my god
benji is smiling sardoch is melting
he's melting oh no sartosh played a great
game he was playing so well and on one turn
doesn't see the queen on the outside the
board full board awareness needs to see
these things and unfortunately for sodos queen he
is laughing at himself he is laughing at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a boates
gambit for the ages and benji fishy wins the group
i just got a shot into bobby hall's
outfit he's just like oh wow it's
not that looks like something right out of the
1970s but he's dressed like dwight from the office
true that's true i literally literally
have the yellow tie mug right here and he
exactly bobby texted me last night and said wait
till you see my outfit but i had no idea this was
what he was going to do this is hilarious oh my
god yeah defending he's slow actual dog water take
attacking can you guys take me
off can you take me outside.com
can you take me off the website
take me off the website get me off congratulations
you are making it to the semifinals critical oh oh
uh are you are you inspired
rain by critical's hair
yeah that's probably what that is yeah
i'm the new i am the new chest jesus
you know
unbelievable sexy what a roller coaster
oh wait she's hovering over there
ah why does she want to eat no
that's
yes yes six zero undefeated yes baby
get it boys
10 minutes it's over boom it goes
here that was not over oh it's over
now maybe we should take a look at tubble
let's see what he's thinking since he
finally has the upper hand in this game um
he has to be a little bit careful though because
his night is under attack don't be scared
i think he's giving himself a pep
talk but you don't have that much time
how's your chest beyond that like how much chest
have you played because you were amazing i mean we
don't know much about you so i'm amazing and i i
started playing like three months ago or something
like that like and it was also not because
of queen's gambit but it was uh because the
the previous spoke times where xqc failed in six
moves after that i began watching more more test
streams and it was thanks to xqc and hikaru so
yeah sweet i don't remember that six moves i don't
know what you're talking about it's just looking
still at the computer he feels the pressure
oh no his queen is going to be trapped after the
knight moves even 92 a simple move like that the
queen cannot move uh if ludwig sees it i think
this is his game and he sees it this is brutal
that will be a pinned queen and there is actually
no way for black to get out of that pin he should
cry oh i didn't even notice it was a pin whoops
yeah even after bishop takes f3 you can play queen
not the best move but i mean again oh
queen takes what we take queen what
she doesn't even see it she's only
looking at her rook under attack
oh oh she i think she spotted it
she took she took its game on oh
what happened see i told you michelle
oh no oh no oh no queen f2 logic misses
it queen of two oh no oh we missed it
and now he's right because me ludwig has a force
made in two and now he's mated what a throw
king he ate and then queen c8 and there's
actually a staircase checkmate oh man
logic through 87's mate mate rookie six green
sevens queen d7 they're three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
the punches just love to realize that he
was made in chicago that's actually a
big question victory charlie's going
off the deep end but frankly jimmy's got
15 seconds i hope he doesn't have a flag
c2 and now he hung the house oh it's done
mate it's not just hanging the rook it's mate
oh can we cut the truck gotcha can we get
this close call pikachu no gifted subs
oh okay well that was far less dramatic that
was i mean okay but next week i mean i don't
no point in looking ahead we've got a crazy
day here today and you know what's hilarious
something just fell from the roof of this
building and hit my camera i'm gonna scream hi
so the new studio we have here is actually not
complete yet we've been doing all kinds of stuff
and what you just saw you can't fake um hey
buddy are you gonna don't shake your head at
me like this is on me buddy i feel so bad but now
the rook is hanging daniel's hanging his rook but
rubio doesn't see it he doesn't have time
oh are we gonna get queenie for night age
four queen eight mate is ruby's gonna see
this oh ruby's ruby is ruby it's no rubios
the background checkmate levy have i
told you about the g6 phone earlier
i know you were right i didn't know you were all
right i didn't want to be right my heart is broken
eclipse can only be a minute long oh queen c6
let's go leave me a minute come on
rain oh my god oh oh man
oh my god this is insane it was jimmy jimmy
can't lose on time okay no stalemate oh my gosh
he just resolved he ran out
of time oh no he resigned
why did he resign you why i literally
just went over real king in game
we're ready we're headed toward mate on a
seven oh don't open your boy in wisconsin
take the queen and don't look back nico yeah
send this to overtime whatever oh and that's
why you pay more attention i feel like obviously
playing on oh no the bishop the bishop no the
a different type of both his gambit
and logic's bishop in the
corner the difference maker
the long-range piece it was
hiding it was hiding on the 80s
oh my god oh my god
no no no oh no i
i don't even i don't even damn it
yeah c3 here is very strong i think
z35 but oh knight d5 oh no he blundered
does reigns see it rain is getting
low on time one minute on the clock
this is his last chance it's
gonna come down to the wire
but now king oh my god
you